I would love to I mean if I could adopt
10 market I would Sheryl Crow opens up
to et about motherhood the 55 year old
singer is mom to ten year old Wyatt and
seven year-old Levi Diana wants to know
we know you're already a mom to two
precious boys is your family complete
would you like to have a baby girl oh my
gosh do you have one that you want to
give me
I think our unit is perfect now and I'm
a little bit older to be a mom
and I want to have all the energy I can
half of the two boys that I have you
know be great to add you know kind of a
dad type guy yeah you know somebody who
just meets us where we are I'm
constantly eyes and heart wide open are
you dating I do date and I can do that
you know in a private setting and it's
great you're such a strong accomplished
woman what kind of guy catches your eye
I'm attractive people that are funny and
people that are curious but you know
having two kids definitely is it creates
a strong weed out process like you know
pretty quickly this is somebody that
you're going to want to be around your
kids yep Cheryl's kids are currently
with her on the outlaw music festival
tour she released her tenth album be
myself in April
would you encourage them following in
your footsteps are they showing musical
ability they are they love it my 10 year
old is really musical my 7 year olds
loves music I don't know how musical he
is yet because he's really into sports
no I would encourage him I want him to
do whatever they want to do raising her
boys in Nashville Cheryl said she's
selective when it comes to work would
you be the new judge on American Idol I
don't know I mean if I had to move
somewhere like you know out of Nashville
I don't know if I you know think you
could I don't know you know it's really
interesting I got asked to do the voice
before the voice even came on that first
season I turned it down because we had
just moved to Nashville and I had Wyatt
and I didn't really want to be back to
LA you know no regrets about that I mean
my bank account would obviously be
exploding right now but um it wasn't the
right time
[Music]
you